[Music]  the gods have sunk an entire city into  the underworld  we should close the five gates  let's make a benefit i'll use a human  the lowest of the low to close the five  gates  a pet who shall be your lowest of the  low  i'm humanity's champion  you have been hand chosen by the gods to  close the gates of the underworld  if you fail mankind will be wide from  the face of the earth  why should i care what happens to  humanity  they took everything from me  i have a destiny and it is to ensure you  do yours  i can't be called only the cry of your  blood can summon me  iselle be brave i am always  going to be with you  you survived you're not as useless as he  thinks  humanity can't do anything alone  on adventure awaits  [Music]  i'm a beacon for monsters great thanks  for coming into our lives kid  [Music]  you